this is northwest arkansas the
birthplace of walmart and the gateway to
the ozarks
which you've probably heard of because
of that netflix show
you owe me a job what
but for the most part this little corner
of the country is off the radar for
today's legions of remote workers
who are itching to bounce from their
high priced high density confines
in cities like san francisco and new
york
but here they all are what
are you seriously duh fantastic
getting a zoom call saying that they've
been selected i feel like i won the
lottery
to help put northwest arkansas on the
map how soon do you think you can
relocate here
wow okay among the many incentivized
relocation programs attracting remote
workers since the pandemic
this one in northwest arkansas offers
ten thousand dollars to those who move
to the area
and stay for at least a year we're
talking about cities like bentonville
rogers and fayetteville i did see
um that fayetteville was also top places
um
for singles to meet people they'll even
throw in a mountain bike
she is ten thousand dollars and and a
bike after receiving more than 24 000
applications
the program called their first 25
winners just a few weeks ago
i wasn't expecting to tell me so now i
gotta oh
goodness i'm definitely gonna call my
mom
it's probably not a huge shock that
hundreds of applicants came from the
pricey tech hub of the bay area
and that includes the portillo family
josue
his wife athena who both work for tech
companies and their three kids
thank god you know i was looking for her
a sign you know
i was uh i was surprised you know and
just full of joy
me and my wife have been talking about
um trying to get a home
a new home for our family our living
situation in san jose is very
very compact it's a two bedroom so
all of us are in that little condo
before the pandemic josue commuted four
hours a day from san jose
for his job in san francisco leaving
just a few precious hours left to spend
with his kids at
night in their 800 square foot home but
even though he was able to work from
home this past year
the portillos still dreamt of owning a
big house the kind they still can't
afford in the bay area
but now with their ten thousand dollar
grant and the blessing of josue's
employer
the fortios which includes josue's
parents say they'll be heading to the
ozark mountains in a few months
where an average home costs less than
270 000
70 cheaper than san jose when we went to
go visit arkansas it felt like a
different country
it just felt like a secret place that we
found
you know like a gym the portillos are
among the growing numbers of remote tech
workers fleeing the broader bay area
and especially san francisco in fact
nearly 40 percent more people moved out
of san francisco during the pandemic
months
compared to the same period a year
earlier the largest increase of any
major city in the country
according to data from moving company
updater
most moved within california but these
states were also top destinations
while cities like austin denver and
seattle are enticing bay area tech
employees more than ever before
this comes as some of the biggest tech
companies like twitter facebook and
salesforce
san francisco's largest private employer
have all announced more permanent remote
work options
i just never had given a thought to
arkansas but if smaller less known
places like northwest arkansas want to
compete for these remote workers
they have to sweeten the deal with cash
and tax incentives in the tens of
thousands
this is going to be amazing like tulsa
oklahoma did
though its ten thousand dollar grants
launched in 2018 the program saw a
dramatic
rise in applicants since the pandemic it
now has more than 500 participants
living and working in tulsa
a newer program called choose topeka
pays up to 15
000 and has brought in 30 workers in
just over a year
right out of the gate it was it exploded
so i mean we had
over 3 500 applications within the first
30 days globally
bob ross runs the topeka program it
really exposed a tremendous
you know pent up demand for people
looking for something new and a fresh
start
and they saw topeka as a possibility for
that
having won a ten thousand dollar grant
from topeka tyler jaggers moved out of
the bay area and bought a 47 thousand
dollar house in topeka that he's fixing
up
i was already thinking about moving
pre-covered
and then once covet kicked in um you
know coupled with things such as
myself i was living next to a fire
evacuation zone
as an indie video game developer who
often dresses up for all the networking
events in town
tyler hopes it will be easier to grow
his company with the lower cost of
living
it's a nice little sleepy town it's not
like bustling there's not a ton of
traffic if you need a park
there's a spot you got a big truck
there's a spot got a small car
enjoy you know so it was great fun
ross sees remote workers like tyler as
an investment
one that will pay off what we found is
that ten thousand dollars in remote
incentives translates
into fifty thousand dollars of economic
impact in just one year
and then you add in just the soft
benefits of you know
uh the intellectual and you know
cultural impact that they'll be making
it's it's ten thousand dollars very well
spent but skeptics of these relocation
programs say the pandemic won't last
forever
and then what san francisco supervisor
matt haney believes the bay area will
always be the home of
innovators and entrepreneurs the tech
industry has had such a
strong ecosystem here that for people
who
want to network who are starting
businesses and want to recruit
folks engineers a lot of that is
concentrated here in the bay area
and even if these relocated tech workers
don't return that doesn't mean a new
wave of talent won't take their place
it may not be the same companies it may
not be the same people
before the pandemic only the biggest
richest companies
could even secure office space here and
that may change
which i think could create a renaissance
for startups
who want to be in san francisco
the portillos say they don't expect to
return to the bay area
i think the only way we would come back
is
the cost of living goes down but i don't
know if that's going to happen
but the family says a fresh start
couldn't have come at a better time
several weeks ago the entire family
contracted covid jose's father was on a
ventilator and they weren't sure he was
going to make it
when he finally came home it was a
miracle the doctors say it was a miracle
and then a few days later we got
the grant it just felt like it's the
same it's always darkest before
the dawn postway's father is expected to
make a full recovery
and now with some extra cash and the
promise of finding affordable property
josue can live close to his parents and
look after them
some sort of acre a lot
maybe even placing her house in
my house next to it having a little
ranch
you